I heard that you have a gadget though
that you love that helps you read at
night so you don't have like just a
normal reading light or you know I I
don't okay I've gone through every book
light in town and none of them you know
they like fall off the page they're not
bright enough I'm gonna switch it off
the page and then it's not as bright on
the other page yeah and also I'm always
traveling so I'm like how can I read in
the car and ever since I was a kid I
mean I don't I don't know about you guys
or you but when I was in the back seat
with my mom if you turn on that light
you were you were dead like like I don't
know what it is about parents where
they're like if you touch that light we
will we will die and I'm just so I never
I'm like oh God I didn't touch anything
in the car yeah I know what is that
about I don't have that same like I I
realize now when I drive and the lights
on I'm like it's fine like it's really
that bad I think I just um innately
became my mom and I'm like don't touch
the light so because I'm afraid they're
gonna leave it on and I'm not gonna see
it okay exactly wear it on the battery
or something logical my mom was like we
can't drive with that on
they're chaos
it's like um totally but no so I um took
it upon myself to go another route with
the book light and found this amazing
light that you wear around your head and
so when you're looking at the page it's
right there I brought you one so you
could actually see thank you
um I think these are for hiking and
outdoor activities but I use them for
reading um so I have one of these and I
play wolf pack with my children in the
backyard with them and we it's dark out
okay I don't have this specific brand
this is fancy mine is more like you know
it costs six dollars but um and this one
you can also tilt it down to the page
might I add oh my gosh wait you
definitely know what this is do you just
sport this in bed while you read look
down like look at your book well Ann
look how amazingly hot I look right and
it's very sexy yeah probably on you am I
I'm like am I um if I could lift my arms
yeah I'm gonna get killed by the way
from my makeup and hair but I'm willing
to risk our friendship over this
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]